We'll discuss each of this in some
detail beginning with public and
private keys.
They're used together to facilitate
the secure transfer of information and
for other purposes.
You can think of them simply as two
numbers that are mathematically related
but in a very complex way.
One of them is public and
is freely available.
The other is private and must be
secured, accessible only to its owner.
Given the freely available public key,
it is prohibitively expensive and
time consuming to calculate
the matching private key.
PKI rests on that core assumption.
If you've ever done banking,
paid bills or
purchased anything on the Internet,
you've used these keys.